[Music]
can you swim
[Music]
just when you thought 2020 couldn't get
any crazier
y'all are out here trying to recreate
the movies baby
a ponzi scheme suspect used an
underwater scooter
to try to flee from the fbi
unsuccessfully
it's too much if you are trying to flee
the fbi
with a sea scooter it's time to
re-evaluate if you find yourself at the
bottom of the ocean
scooting hey you've made a
series of life choices that led you to
that point
this man named matthew piercy was
under water for 25 minutes trying to
scoot
around with his little sea scooter it
goes like four miles an hour
and the detectives are on land just like
watching him and he's down there
thinking to himself
dude i'm getting away with it he saw
national treasure one time
right y'all remember the national
treasure scene this is a scene where
nicholas cage is being chased by the fbi
and he escapes by jumping into the river
and escaping on a sea scooter
this guy thinks to himself hey
if if cage can do it i could do it
listen guys i'm just telling you the
news these are the facts this really
happened
so he's scooting around but what he
doesn't realize and what national
treasure doesn't show you because the
movies aren't real
is guess what comes up when you're
underwater
scooting bubbles
the doj says that piercy spent time
underwater submerged where all the
the detectives and the fbi could do is
see the bubbles
but the thing is they can see the
bubbles so this guy this guy's scooting
around at four miles an hour
at the at the lake depths lake shasta
it's freezing by the way at lake shasta
they thought he had hypothermia
afterwards he didn't
but he thinks he's getting away with it
and turns out they're just like walking
alongside as he's scooting you could
probably walk that fast four miles an
hour
it's nothing so he gets caught he's
going to jail
and now they're saying he's a flight
risk of course
because he's trying to escape in
underwater submergibles and it looks
like he might get
life in prison he's facing several
counts of potentially
20-year long sentences so it does look
like he will be going to jail for a very
long time and i
say two things first of all good show
the scammers what you get when you run
ponzi's games
number two to the future prison warden
make sure you don't give this guy a rock
hammer
we know that this is a man with some
ideas he might uh
get to shaw shanking his way out of
there we don't know
but this just goes to show boys crime
pays temporarily look he was banking
35 million dollar ponzi scheme but
eventually
you're going to get caught you're going
to look like a fool and we're going to
call you out for it
his ponzi scheme was all built on the
idea of algorithmic trading but there
was only one algorithm going on
you gave him money you lost money
because he spent it on
houseboats house renovations all this
stuff total scumbag
and uh looks like he's getting what he
deserves next time you think your day's
bad
just imagine freezing your butt off in
lake shasta
trying to evade the fbi on a sea scooter
anyway that's it see you next time and
don't forget to smash
like and subscribe thank
[Music]
of you while you're honest